malvoyante depuis l'âge de 15 ans
Dominique Boucheron perd la vue il y a 2
ans cette sportive accomplie doit alors
adapter sa passion à son handicap le
vélo se transforme en tendemme et la
course est menée par un guide Dominique
et Laurent se sont rencontrés il y a un
an et demi grâce à l'association
Valentin oui pour être efficace et
performant sur le parcours du triathlon
ils ne doivent faire qu'un alors la
confiance elle est primordiale
euh oui ça c'est ça c'est primordial et
oui ben fatalement après on s'entend
plus ou moins bien avec certains pilotes
mais après au bout d'un moment on roule
avec les pilotes avec qui on s'entend
bien et avec Laurent oui on rigole bien
on a une super
complicité Laurent le guide pratique le
triathlon depuis 3 ans à Versailles il
va prendre part à son premier triathlon
and disport où la nage est remplacée par
le canoé kayak je me suis rendu compte
c'était plus facile de de trouver cette
osmose avec un un un équipier une
équipière mal voyante ou non voyante
parce que le handicap nous oblige à nous
pilotes et voyant à à créer les choses
différemment à parler davantage à
communiquer plus avec son équipier donc
finalement c'est une une vraie richesse
et et on apprend plus vite au-delà de la
performance sportive c'est le moment de
complicité qui réunit ce duo on naborde
pas le triathlon du haut dans l'objectif
de faire un résultat avec une logique de
performance et surtout l'objectif de
partager quelque chose entre équipi et
puis avec les gens qui vont participer à
cet événement dans le handis sport le
pilote est souvent l'athlète de l'ombre
mais pas au tri en duo oh il y a pas de
méritant non il y a pas de méritant on
fait du sport voilà moi je peux pas
faire du sport toute seule donc je
dirais que que le pilote est méritant de
de de consacrer du temps pour
nous il il y a pas de pour moi il y a
pas de méritant il y a des sportifs
c'est tout une cinquantaine d'équipes
seront présentes à la 3e édition du
triathlon national en duo au château de
versaill Dominique Boucheron ne
participera pas à la compétition avec
Laurent mais avec un pilote qu'elle ne
connaît pas enc c elle devra s'adapter
très rapidement comme au
quotidien